i'm always sleepy yes i know i've known
you for a good 20 years
no no i don't think you know how just
how sleepy i am well you're a man who
claims to be sleepy but you don't show
the signs of sleepiness well he just
yawned well a yawn yeah you're making
your well does constantly having red
eyes
count because my eyes are just always
red
you see i don't notice that i do you
don't notice that i don't see that in
there no i know it's good mentioning how
tired you are all the time that i hear
that i pick up one yeah i think i
probably use more energy than the
average person acting like i'm not tired
and that's probably why i'm so tired
because i'm at it so it's almost like a
cyclical sort of like self-perpetuating
issue
right it's a lot of run stop run stop
well welcome back to the podcast yeah uh
this is uh
it's always sunny in philadelphia i'm
glenn howerton i'm rob mcelhoney and
charlie today i guess did we do that
last time do we say who we were i guess
i don't know is that we're finding it
we're just figuring this out guys still
figuring it out this is only episode two
and once again we'll uh we've already
begun and then we'll talk for a while
and then it'll just sort of
end
guys we just watched episode two of the
show charlie wants an abortion do any of
you guys seem to recall when that was
written in what sequence because that's
not how we shot them that was like maybe
the i want to say that was the third one
the second one we've wrote
was the second one we wrote but i
believe it was maybe the third one we
shot i i don't know it feels like in
watching it that after watching the
first episode that we aired i definitely
remember thinking maybe we talked about
this on the podcast i don't know why
anybody would watch the show but
watching that one i'm like oh okay i see
some i see some funny stuff yeah i like
that one holds up to me i like yeah yeah
the kid's great
it seems like everybody's all the guest
cast is amazing in it yeah we were still
finding d d's character in that is was
still sort of like the wet blanket yeah
guys but she's so funny in the scene
with me definitely at the mall with the
waitress
yeah yeah she finds her moments
she knows that'd be funny yeah that's
not an issue yeah she always knew how to
elevate it but you're right in terms of
the writing we hadn't quite found her
character yet and what was funny about
it that was the only episode i
vividly remember writing on a yellow
legal pad and
showing you my notes
like the scenes with the kid i remember
that i actually remember the offices we
were in i remember that was when we were
all having conversations about what the
title of the show could be
because it shouldn't be it's always
sunny in philadelphia because that's
insane it's a terrible terrible title
it's too much of a mouthful
and we had
a bet go actually we did a bet in the
office do you remember 500. we didn't
have a bet we offered people money no we
know
it was two hundred dollars
sure yeah we weren't five hundred dollar
men yet
yeah probably right yeah yeah i'm pretty
sure it was two hundred dollars like oh
and that's steep yeah that's steep yeah
200 200 bucks for whoever could come up
with the best title yeah and we didn't
go with the best one no no you could
make it i mean we went with the worst
one you know what i've got that i think
i have that list somewhere i should try
to find that out i've got it no i know i
have it
the only one i remember is jerks but
what else possibly could we have come up
with i don't know jerks jerks would have
been better i think jerks was way up
there i remember and i don't remember
why we didn't why didn't we go with
jerks do we feel like it was too
too cute reductive too cute
i don't know i have no idea but this
stupid title won by war of attrition i
think we just got to the end and we were
like
oh screw it screw it it's memorable it's
but it's not no it isn't it's not
memorable it's a bad title it's a bad
title it's a bad title and it continues
to be and then people but then they talk
about it they go no it's actually a
great title don't you see and i'm like
no no no yeah yeah yeah everyone's like
i've had so many people come out they're
like i love it because it's not always
sunny in philly and that's was and it's
funny because of that
like yeah yeah i guess so
i mean that was the original home movie
was actually titled it's always sunny on
tv
we were originally playing ourselves and
we were originally actors who
occasionally worked but mainly we just
wanted to have vain characters who had a
lot of time on their hands
and so originally we were all actors so
the original title of the show was it's
always sunny on tv
and that came from i was at the gym i
remember was at crunch gym on sunset
boulevard in west hollywood what are you
working on yeah what were you worried i
believe at the time i was stretching
when this song came you just went to the
gym to stretch i know it's post-workout
i'm gonna just say i'm gonna throw this
in real quick this story has been told
so many times over the last 15 years
that anybody who's listening to this has
probably already heard it 15 times
however i think you should tell it but
anybody who has access to their phone
should just hit like that thing where
you can make it go faster yeah you can
make it go yeah i will say this i don't
remember the crunch gym aspect of it i
also went to a crunch gym so but i don't
remember crunches gym affiliation with
our successful show so for the people of
crunch i think they might want to hear
it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're still out there crunching yeah
well also like i i don't i think they
are crunch still exists are they
crunching i don't know yeah i think they
are too many people get crunched they're
like oh man i crunched myself back that
was such a fun gym to go to there's
always there's always great people to
watch at that gym you know dave navarro
was always there i was always like
that's weird he was that dude was there
every single time i was there and i was
there at random times so i was like
he's here all the [ __ ] time crunches
crunching he's just crunching getting
his crunch on yeah yeah
i think people have read this story but
i don't know that they've heard our
voices telling it and that's what makes
it special okay okay
so um so i'm at crunch
i've just finished my workout uh i'm
doing some stretches don't ask me why
but i'm listening to i don't know if i
have my [ __ ] on shuffle or if i was
actually listening to an aha album
it's the their most it's the one with
take on me on it it's actually great
album
and because they're catching songs and
there's a song and there was a song that
came off
well so the song that came on was the
sun always shines on tv
i believe is the actual title of the
show and that is the chorus of the song
and i just remember thinking like oh
that's a good that's a good title for
the show it's always sunny or like some
version of that and then i don't
remember how we actually how that
morphed into it's always sunny on tv but
it's it's based on the aha song and that
would have made a lot more sense if we
were doing a show it's always runny on
tv is a good title it is yeah it's
always funny
it makes no
yes but there is something to like
sometimes something that's too
premeditated like the fact that it's not
a good title is why it's a good title
yeah right is that it's not like jerks
is too cute and like too polished and
i don't know like the message it's too
networking it's too networking it is too
accessible yeah
we lost some of our street cred with
that title yeah yeah in a way yeah
i don't know that's corporate arts man
that's music
yeah man
[ __ ] that yeah yeah
for me man i want the accidental title
yeah
i want the default title yeah because
they couldn't come up with something
good give me the jackson pollock of
titles man
now max straighten this in this episode
very straight extremely straight and
deniably straight and uh
yeah but we always knew eventually in
season 11 we were going to take this
character
now we talked about it extensively we
knew that once we were yeah as you said
11 seasons in we were gonna you know
because we knew we were going to go 11
seasons for those of
fans that we knew were going to invest
this much time in it
yeah um that kid now yes how old is he
oh he's gotta be he's gotta be mid
yeah how old was that kid my god i mean
he he was probably what 11 years old
when he shot that so and that was
16 years ago so he's probably 20 in his
late 20s
spencer spencer spencer we got to have
him we got to have him back we should
have spencer he was great he was great
we were commenting on uh so i remember
the night before shooting a couple of
those scenes like having a few ideas
like lying in bed thinking about things
and being like oh i should have hit me
with a pool stick that'd be funny and i
was like i should have him spit right in
my face when i'm doing the thing with
the keys yeah
but we didn't tell the director that
we didn't talk to the directors very
much in those early seasons we just kind
of did whatever we wanted and we
expected them to know so spencer hauls
off and spits right in my face and i
remember
the director like because they were
across the street like yelling cut and
like trying to run across the street
like stop the cut and i remember
thinking like oh
fortunately we got enough of the take
out before you could hear him on camera
but i remember being irritated that he
would yell cut which is like it's like a
guy does a [ __ ] stunt and breaks his
arm you don't yell cut and you're like
no you [ __ ] i broke my arm for that
shot you [ __ ]
like i just got spit in the face yeah
keep it like what are you doing don't so
just to be clear
i get charlie's point you're saying if
somebody breaks their arm in a scene
let's just say it's a four or five
minute long scene we should we should
continue with the scene you make sure
that whatever [ __ ] shot you're on
you have that and then you yell cut no
glenn is saying he's so badass that if
he breaks his arm don't you're not
saying you would hurt another actor
you're saying as director he was saying
and i'm with you
if i don't tap out of this cut god damn
keep rolling because i just broke my
[ __ ] for this right and if it's a really
good take and you ruin it and i have a
broken arm then we both lose i'm with
you
the show must go on yeah spencer daniels
he played a young brad pitt in
benjamin buttons oh was he in benjamin
baton i thought yes i thought brad pitt
played young brad pitt and benjamin
buttons i thought that was the whole
thing it's benjamin bataan's yes
benjamin's batons but he continues to
he he ages back he ages backwards and
then he hits a certain point where even
even brad pitt can't play right an
eight-year-old you need spencer that's
when spencer
brad pitt as people always have he could
definitely play in it but he could play
a baby he could play he could do it all
he could play i don't remember anything
with batons
there were small little round things
that keep your shirt together oh i
thought it was like the parade baton no
well no they were but they were small
and they were around and they kept their
the person shot
in the form of a baton yeah one thing we
noticed from this episode was that we
had some certain level of
interest in in some kind of social
commentary then we noticed that there
was one tiny line as we were watching it
where dee's cutting the limes and then
just for filler before someone walks in
dennis is commenting on how she's
cutting the limes that's that's that's
too thin and that much
i think charlie said as we were watching
it that's what the entire show is now
like right what we realized was we can
keep making these kinds of shows but
what's really funny are the
conversations that happen in between
sort of the bigger conversations we're
having yeah having getting into a whole
thing about whether the limes should be
thin or thick yes actually that i
believe did come from us talking about
like how i mean i think some of that
because we were trying to go for
accuracy like how would a bartender
really cut limes right we were trying we
were trying to say this was a real bar
these were human beings
well yeah yeah but also too you know you
get 15 years in and then in the first
season you're like well we did we did uh
racism and abortion and cancer cancer
and then like what's left what's all
you're just left with lines uh yeah yeah
you know like that's it you're like well
i guess we do an episode about limes
yeah we'd probably figure out an episode
about fruit the thickness and thinness
of them yeah maybe we also realize that
it's just straight up funnier to talk
about
wanting chips and you should have gotten
ships at the hamburger store getting
real heated about something that's
relatively minor however
also weirdly relatable because yeah
we've all been in that situation where
you've got a little bag of chips and
your body's like let me have some of
those chips you're like it's a small bag
of chips here and i'm loving it and i'm
hungry and i don't want to give you my
chips because they're delicious to me
and i you should have gotten them yeah
you had them at the vending machine and
you should have also gotten the chips
and now you want a sip of my fanta too
get [ __ ] yeah we do both you know we
do both we we got scenes like that but
then we have time's up for the gang
which is fairly recent and we're talking
about the time's up movement which is a
big you know yeah thing that happened
but they can't all be yeah
they can't all be there that was megan
megan did that megan wrote that so if
anybody's upset with that one like
that's megan yeah that was that was her
that was her fault that was her fault
that was her fault
megan wrote rob grabs another woman by
her vagina and lifts her up into that
yeah
she's a woman she's a woman she's a
woman
also a notable uh guest star in that
episode is mr cormac bluestone uh and
for those of you who don't know who
cormac bluestone is he plays jimmy doyle
in the episode but more importantly he
became our resident composer and helped
us compose most of the original songs
that have ever been on the show and then
not just the original songs but like a
lot of score and yeah when we have like
a really moody episode and we need
something very specific he'll like
last season for the laser tag stuff we
wanted like a sort of shining-esque
theme
and he nailed that did he uh he did that
yeah i didn't remember that okay yeah
but yeah very talented guy
charlie you've been you were friends
with him before he was one of the
williamstown theater festival guys i
knew like jimmy simpson and david
hornsby and uh right a lot of people
that we know came from that connection
yeah nate mooney yeah yeah the
williamstown theater festival check it
out it's somewhere
where is it williamstown status
yeah but that's not a state so what
state is that in it's in the state of
massachusetts oh the westernmost corner
there well listen if you ever find
yourselves in the state of massachusetts
and you're looking for some good theater
check out the williamstown theater
festival and you're not getting any of
my chips during intermission
i want to talk about how much it hurt to
get pelted with those eggs in that
episode okay yeah it really hurts one
one caught me right in the air but we
didn't stop and yell cut one caught him
in the ear this is we got the shot
that's a very salient point and it's
exactly what i was trying to say earlier
yeah it's exactly what i'm talking about
100 with you here pal yeah with the same
work ethic when it comes to that which
is like let's get the shot man but what
if the line wasn't scripted but you
screamed out
dear god
my eye has been pierced and then we look
up and your eyes falling out of your
head again should we stop or should we
keep going i think an extra three or
four seconds to make sure that you've
got that shot and it's in the can yeah
it's not gonna make the difference
between whether i lose my sight in that
eye or not yeah yeah cause like also
what am i doing in the scene like is it
really good take for me i want that yeah
well we do cross cover we do cross cover
yeah yeah so you know just because your
eyes out doesn't mean i'm not yeah you
weren't in that scene no you're just
talking and what are you doing
theoretical theoretical you theoretical
me yeah um i i believe we started
shooting that scene though and people
were throwing eggs at me and they were
not bursting they were just bouncing off
of me and that hurt even more so then
somebody had the bright idea of just
poking holes in the eggs so that they
would explode every time they hit me and
uh
that was a good idea and it was
disgusting and i hated it um you know
but i did it i did it because i'm a
professional
don't sigh little known fact i did it
because in fact there is an uh an actor
that had a scene that we hired a friend
of ours olivia munn we didn't she wasn't
a friend at the time you guys mentioned
that when we were watching the episode i
had no memories yes yes well i didn't i
don't remember it either but i bumped
into her yes at a gym not crunch crunch
and um you gotta she was she was can't
you tell and uh
she's told me that story where she was
supposed to be oh
caitlin's that was her excuse why didn't
she show up that something was like it
was not her fault was it not yeah no it
wasn't it was like a scheduled thing
oh it's only twice that's happened on
her show where the actor didn't show up
one was olivia munn yes and the other
was michael madsen yeah he just straight
up didn't show michael maxx i've never
seen that before he fled the country he
led the state he
i believe he got out of the state of
california they're like the man's in
manitoba canada
he's right right he's not gonna make it
yeah he's not here he owes me he's gone
he owes like some uh spousal support but
i remember i do remember it was a
spousal support said he did not want to
support that situation and he's like
guys i'm so sorry i'm out of the country
yeah but his agent was like guess what
we got tom seismore on hold yeah so
apparently his agent's life yeah even
better i got i got all the crazies man i
got you know i got all the wild guys
and so the science where it comes in
crushes that's a different episode we'll
talk about a different episode but then
i do remember
you know like six months later we got
word back from michael madsen's agent
who was like reached out and said hey
guys just fyi you know michael is still
like a huge fan of the show and would
love to would love to come back on oh
and we were like oh so sorry i'm sorry
he
he didn't show up straight up just
didn't show up one day yeah and now he's
he's looking to come back yeah okay
we'll consider it yeah noted
by the way
i love him he's great i love michael
yeah i mean i don't i can't speak on
behalf of him i'm sure he's done
terrible things or not no bad things i
don't know and this is not an
endorsement leave me alone good just get
off me cut this cut oh
you can't do a podcast these days
because
everybody breathing down your neck
this is crazy
anyway i would also like to point out
that in that first season we were all
and i don't remember why this was
everybody's wearing a hybrid
of their clothes from their wardrobe but
also there was wardrobe
and also like we had a props department
so we had props but also some of the
problems were like ours yeah what the
hell was that why was that i've never
seen anything on a real tv show it was
real like student film production
quality
and we don't need to get into the exact
amount we were paid at the time but it
was it was when we tell people that what
we got paid it's almost like it was not
it's not possible yeah
i don't know how they got away with that
well because they they were like
aren't there unions and like we had we
were all sag and wga and was the show
even sag in the first season or was it a
half character it was afterwards
it was after and i think that they
didn't want us to be
wga either in fact we might not have
been wga oh boy here we go hey you guys
want to talk about unions
um i'm curious on your take on this so
going back to actors just not showing up
on set i've always wondered this about
like you hear stories about like um
you know super famous actors that are
elusive in a way and that's part of
their lore like well they just you know
like they'll have a meeting with the
director the meeting goes well and then
the director's just wondering hey on the
first day of filming you know this dude
may or may not show up
what the [ __ ] is that like it like how
how is that
that's not charming right that's not
good it's not no that's crazy like you
know i feel like those are the kind of
shenanigans that are less and less
tolerated these days and i i could be
wrong about that but i feel like more
and more people are just like no [ __ ]
that guy wait i don't want to work with
him or her i just it's not worth it it's
not worth it there's too many talented
people out there and life's too short
well it's like the guy who like you know
the key grip who lives in santa clarita
right who wakes up at four in the
morning right who doesn't get to see his
kid in the morning you know who hasn't
seen his kid for a week or whatever
drives like
in the middle of the middle of night all
the way to well here's the good news he
still gets paid he gets he still gets
paid so he's not that upset that guy
santa clarita ah him maybe yeah he's
like i'll hold a boom mic or not either
way i'm getting paid i don't give a [ __ ]
right um
what else yeah what else what else rob
what do you got man what can you talk
about these days
can you cover i have heard people say
many times though they're like yeah
it was just much more grounded the show
was much more grounded in season one
that's true which actually makes it more
terrifying yeah it was it was more
grounded and we were almost we were
truly presenting these people as the
most awful people on the planet of
course who always get their comeuppance
but we were saying like these people
like really do exist yo that was very
important to us i remember i mean we
really wanted to like make it feel even
though it was scripted we wanted to kind
of feel improvised we wanted the acting
to be very not sitcommy
and then that went away in season two uh
when we realized that it would be
funnier but we realize it's a sitcom
well there is it is a sitcom and maybe
that's okay there is some purity to
making something where us as the
filmmakers the actors have no idea
what's going to be funny about it to
anyone else
right so that you really
can't rely on any character trait you've
come up with you can't rely on any sort
of story element you really have to
invent something from scratch so that
the pure inventiveness of it it's kind
of like the accidental title that we
have which is that
you know we're not really trying to
squeeze season one into a box of this is
exactly like this other show we were
really trying to invent our own thing
and
season two we're trying to
squeeze it into the box of season one in
a sense like we're trying to grow on it
but it's also based on something we've
done so
maybe there is like a purity to that
which is sort of exciting to watch which
is that it's yeah it could i wish i
could see it objectively i wish i could
look at it objectively it's just
impossible it's impossible
well it was definitely not through lack
of trying we we grind we were killing
ourselves we were we were killing
ourselves and we were swinging for the
fences as i recall first of all i never
understood why they let us make the show
i was like you want us to write it we're
not right okay sure we're not writers
but we'll do it
and i just thought like
we may as well swing for the fences and
go for it because there's no [ __ ] way
the show's ever gonna get picked up now
i understand having watched it again i
haven't seen one of those episodes and i
mean seriously i think 10 well over 10
years wow remember how bad my stomach
problems were like i had really bad
stomach problems reflux i had well i had
a [ __ ] ulcer oh yeah and then yeah
and then it just like suddenly went away
but i realized the way that it went away
was i'm looking i'm looking at the
episodes so i'm realizing well that i
weighed like 130 pounds i didn't barely
ate anything all i did was drink coffee
and smoke cigarettes all day long yeah
all day long why did you feel good i
didn't even drink alcohol that much like
during that time period i was just
drinking i mean like on the weekends but
not every night like i do now
okay
right at the time i was just waking up
in the morning
drinking as much coffee as i could to
get me through the day and smoking a ton
of cigarettes and then being like what
is wrong with my stomach i don't
understand
this doesn't make any sense i'm a
youngish person
how long have you been off coffee now
i've been off coffee i don't know five
years yeah you and coffee don't mix no
don't mix well with the coffee but i
could drink the coffee without the
cigarettes but the combination was tough
but i did that for a good 10 years
shut up uh guys this episode brought to
you by coffee coffee
[ __ ] you but you guys you're welcome
this episode also brought to you by
cigarettes
cigarettes
you're dead
we're
we're still around we're still a thing
that's true we're cigarettes you know
you want them but you know we're bad
[Laughter]
some of you can resist us and some of
you are just gonna die
taking aunts and uncles since 1843
quitting smoking was one of the hardest
things i've ever done there was a point
in where i was like you know what
i'll shave a good 15 years off my life i
don't care i love it this way right you
almost just gave in you were like [ __ ]
it yeah but now in your mid-40s you're
happy you haven't been smoking oh yeah
you know back a day since your 20s can
you imagine you would feel very bad i
feel very well you feel totally fine
like certain people we know that like
smoke
and are fine and they smoke till brought
to you by cigarettes you'll be fine
brought to you by cigarette five
look at that one guy's dad he still
smokes and he's fine
cigarettes
still cool
ah god i do miss smoking though oh it's
delicious i love it every time i like on
the rare rare rare occasion that because
i will occasionally and it's very rare
these days have a cigarette and i'm
always thinking like oh this is going to
be gross and it's not i love the last
cigarette i had
socially prior to that it had been five
years but i smoked like four cigarettes
the night of your 40th birthday party oh
yeah everybody we went to some bar
everybody
everybody got so drunk it was the
drunkest i'd ever seen david hornsby
yeah howard's been winning he would fund
david which fun dave was on fire fun day
yeah fun day of got sloppy 40th glenn's
my 40th 40th birthday party so that was
five five karaoke players gaslight
gaslight gas lamp yeah what the hell's
the name of that place david got so
unbelievably drunk that night that i
don't think he drank for like another
two years and the next day
we saw him and he was like he had a
rough night and apparently
he peed in his dresser oh that's right
yeah yeah he woke up and emily emily's
like david what are you doing and he's
like shot my god i'm going to the
bathroom she's like david wake up and
he's like i'm fine i'm fine and she's
like wake you're peeing in a drawer
he was pissing in his drawer what a fool
in like his sock drawer oh boy yeah and
then he was like i'm gonna get off the
sauce for a little bit
yeah it's not really a good move yeah
not a good look yeah so that was the
last time you had that time i had a
cigarette i had like five or six
cigarettes and then i um are you like me
though because i think it's more of the
chemicals that i want you know what i'm
saying like if somebody hands me an
american spirit i'm like not interested
no you want the drugs yeah i want i want
if i'm going i want to go all in i want
well i want a camel
camel with no filter yeah absolutely
because it's still got the chemicals
then it just doesn't have the filter
yeah yeah i want whatever they're adding
to their to whatever camel whatever joe
camel is adding
to those cigarettes that's what i want
that's what i want
you have to give me like real tobacco
i'm like this is kind of funny when you
want to smoke the fake ones in the
movies it's
brutal that shit's not right
for those of you not in the movie
industry
when you smoke cigarettes you're not
really allowed to smoke real cigarettes
and things anymore because it's a hazard
to the people around you so they give
you these herbal cigarettes that are
just [ __ ] awful so when you see
people smoking in movies now unless they
were shooting in like bucharest or
something
it's these herbal things and they're
really [ __ ] gross
really [ __ ] they're bad yeah they're
bad but then the ritual of it is still
nice you know like the the lighting
something and the
cigarettes
the ritual is nice the ritual is nice
you'll miss the rituals we can make a
lot of money endorsing things that
you're just not allowed can we just like
wait you know we should we should be
endorsing things that we want more often
just endorsing cigarettes and porn like
let's just do that be like hey
cigarette's a porn company we'll we'll
endorse you yeah we'll and then make a
lot of money definitely any kind of
booze right
porn you love us you'll never admit it
[Music]
well i guess it just sort of ended in
there oh yeah that this this is good i
mean it just you know yeah
you still tired something
did that invigorate you at all did you
get less tired i do feel invigorated i
do that was invigorating
so is it just the engagement thing if
you're not engaged you're going to feel
tired yeah but it takes a lot to get me
engaged these days because everything
bores me
everything's boring that sounds like
depression oh definitely oh absolutely
how
yeah but it's like you know then i'll
miss the manic phase mm-hmm you know
because when i'm manic
that's a that's when you're fun that's
oh man you know everybody's fun when
they're manic yeah i think i i think i
have like a very very minor case of
bipolar disorder okay where like you
know i go through like extreme highs and
or like not like semi-extreme highs i
don't know if that's something you can
have a minor case of can you just have a
splash of it i have a splash of bipolar
i don't know i don't know i'm
self-diagnosing here which is what any
good person does
uh just poke around the internet and
look for symptoms and see if anything
matches up with how you're feeling you
should be able to find something yeah
yeah it's hard for me to get real jazzed
up about stuff though and stay engaged i
just had to get [ __ ] bored very
easily
you know but this is fun i found this
very stimulating megan what do you think
you should come get a thumbs
well i know but she could chime in every
now and then if she wants i mean it
would be nice that she's very funny very
smart very intelligent no
she
thumbs
not want to be exposed the way we are
she knows this is career suicide
well we've learned a lot today uh we've
learned that uh we've learned about
crunch gym gosh what a fun trip down in
memory lane guys what a fun trip down
memory lane learned glenn's
touch with a splash of bipolarism
self-diagnosed impossible awesome the
show is brought to you by depression
depression we're gonna get you
depression there's always cigarettes
booze porn and crack
and sunny and that's always sunny and
funny that's always something that's
always something nice to hear
your choice
people say you know i i've gotten that
many times over the years people say
they're like they've had a rough go or
they're sad those are my favorites yeah
those are my that's my favorite they
watch sonny that makes them laugh yeah
it's the best kiss scenario you make it
thing you put it on the world you hope
it reaches people touches people moves
them in their lives that's a nice thing
it's good
thank you for telling us when that
happens yeah we like hearing that yeah
it's very gratifying snap glenn out of
his depression sure a little bit i mean
yeah
but don't do it too much because then
he'll get bored then he'll be bored of
you saying it yes yes i know yeah
hey guys i'm gonna go take a nap
[Music]
you